a little moisture on the bottom this is
very good
i'm actually shocked i thought it would
be overdone
thank you son hey guys i'm katie and
today i'm reviewing the go
sun solar oven i'm going to test how
well it works if the food it makes taste
good and if this is something you should
buy this is supposed to be for camping
which is something i really really love
to do
also might come in handy during the
apocalypse i don't know
i'm liking the idea of using the power
of the sun to cook all right let's do
this
i just want to show you that it's
showing you all the places you can take
this on the go
on the road at home on the water on your
yacht if you have one
and then while you camp which is really
what i'm excited about it heats up to
550 degrees fahrenheit which that seems
pretty hot cooks in clouds and freezing
cold well that's good today we have a
pretty sunny day so we're not gonna
be able to test out if it actually works
in clouds but that's all right it does
look like you're cooking in a
tubular fashion it looks like it's a
tube that's going into
a sunglass case it looks like a large
case your dad would have
let's open her up
oh we've got some silicone dishes here
i'm assuming
instructions oh it comes with its own
very oh it's like a backpack you can put
it in here
and go on a hike and then make your
friends a casserole
we'll find out oh here's the case we saw
on the front oh and this is it this is
the thing
it has a nice weight to it which i
always like it makes it feel better
quality
oh my gosh the power of the sun when i
look at this like if you were like let's
make food
i would be a little confused just
because i've never cooked
in a tube this thing is definitely not
gonna be about presentation
but when you're camping it doesn't
really matter and then you've got these
reflectors
and something with science happens and
it heats it up
and that's how science works so i've
read the user guide i think i know how
to set it up first we'll
open this guy and there's this thing
called the prop stick which you
rotate keeps it open and then there are
the kickstand they're calling in the
back and this is the stabilizer
it goes in like that and it sits up
like so so in the front there is the go
sundial right here and there's a little
red
dot and what they want you to do is get
it in front of the sun
so that the shadow of the red dot is in
the center i'm gonna test out three
things today
first how well it boils water we're
gonna make some hot cocoa
i feel like it's a camping staple then
we'll try some omelettes
for breakfast and then we'll end with
dessert which is going to be a little
bit harder we're going to try to make
some brownies
first thing we'll do is add some water
to our
tube here let's see how much this can
take
oh okay great that was about two cups
and then they call this the tray
and you're gonna take the silicone cap
off the top which i think is pretty
handy
and place it over your tube
and then we've got to find the sun
this feels like a science trip like like
we've taken a field trip
i think that's right i think i got it i
think i got it like immediately
so i'm going to let this sit for about
45 minutes and we'll come back and
have some hot cocoa in the meantime i'm
just gonna go
set up ten we'll have a ton
you guys it's been one hour i had to let
it go a little bit longer but we're
finally
boiling and it's pretty exciting i feel
like i have a superpower when you're
cooking with the sun so now it's time to
have
hot cocoa i'm using a mitt because it
feels
so hot and if you guys can see there's
steam coming out of here
is this hot to touch oh no this is so
cool this is
this is perfectly cold this is crazy so
i'm gonna take this string thing here
and i think that's gonna help me pour oh
it's hot yes
so that was almost all the water and it
made one big cup of cocoa
we'll add our hot chocolate
it's melting this chocolate the true
test though i call this the marshmallow
test is it hot enough
that when i put these marshmallows on it
will melt them
all right you guys it's time for the
taste test it's hot i hope it's not as
hot as the sun
cause i'm gonna burn my mouth all right
let's do it
oh so good because it's
it's just it's so hot i i can't believe
that it was as boiling as it is
i'm definitely gonna have to let this
cool down a little bit before i consume
more
but this worked out really well i'm
really excited why don't we try to make
an omelette
we're just gonna make a standard
omelette here some eggs peppers
cheese a little bit of bacon and i keep
calling this an omelette this is more
like an open-faced omelet
or scrambled eggs kind of with just
toppings if we can only make three eggs
at a time again
it's cool that it's using the power of
the sun but time wise it takes
a little bit longer so if you were
camping with a lot of people
this would be kind of tricky so you can
either grease this or
line the tube tray with parchment
i've lined it with parchment now we're
gonna pour in our eggs
so now i'll add in some cheese do some
peppers
gotta have breads and greens and last
but not least
bacon because i like
oh i didn't add my seasoning fidgery
fidge
i'm gonna add my seasoning now don't do
it like me do it when you mix your eggs
together
again you can only do two omelettes or
eggs at a time
before i put it into the solar cooker
i'm actually gonna find the sun first
that way we don't have a bunch of
movements and things spilling and oh
perfect so here we go
this is a little bit tricky it's a
little i can imagine me
tripping and dropping this so this is
supposed to take 25 minutes i'm a little
suspect because the water
took an hour instead of 45 minutes but
we'll come back at 25 and see how it
looks
do your thing son son don't look into
the sun kids
all right it's time to check on our
omelettes
i think it's about ready this is about
40 minutes
later and we finally have two cooked
eggs
the way this cooks is this side gets hot
first and then the heat
distributes upwards the issue with this
is that now you have
really overcooked eggs at the top and
then this side took forever to cook at
the bottom
some egg got below the parchment so
online they recommended greasing and
doing the parchment we both greased and
did parchment
i think you maybe just lose the
parchment all together
because it doesn't really seem to work
that well and
it's tube food it's tube food but hey
let's give it a taste and then we'll
know
it's a little overcooked it's a little
rubbery if you're camping this is
it's fuel if you're if it's the
apocalypse this is gourmet
i'm gonna give this about a b b minus it
was
fine let's try brownies and see if this
guy can
win me back over
[Music]
it's our final test brownies i'm very
excited about this but i am also
nervous i feel like we're going to get
some over baked ones and then maybe some
fudgy ones which i love fudgy we're just
going to make
a typical box brownie mix here keep it
easy when you're camping
you don't have time to get too frou-frou
when i was getting ready for the
brownies i went
and washed actually this tray and it was
pretty
tricky to clean off even though we had
greased it
it wasn't easy to to do usually when i
go camping i stick to the classic
s'mores but let me know in the comments
what kind of desserts you guys like to
eat when you camp we're going to be
testing out these silicone
molds for this one what i like about the
silicone molds is you can get your own
that's fun it also says it's going to
double in size so
i am going to try to only fill this
halfway so our trays are filled
i got to find the sun for the third and
final time today
the sun is right behind me here so let's
see
can i find the sun i'm gonna find
sunshine in my life i found the sun you
guys remember that song
ready to go feels like i'm like loading
up a spaceship or a rocket launcher
we're gonna let this go for 25 minutes
so i have a feeling it's going to be
closer to an hour
and we'll be back to see if we get some
yummy yummy brownies
we checked them at 25 minutes and they
were not done so we let them go
for 40 minutes total and
oh they look so good
this side got a little bit more baked
than the left side just because again
it's
it's cooking in a lime the heat's moving
up
but overall not too bad you'll
definitely want to let this cool down a
little bit because it is very hot when
it comes out
none of this food has looked super
glamorous but if you're surviving the
apocalypse or going camping
who cares oh do you see that got a
little moisture on the bottom
it looks a little fudgy which i like
bottoms up
yes thank you son
wow you know what if you like an end
piece of a brownie it kind of tastes
like that because the outside's a little
crusty
but then it also feels like you get a
center brownie because it's super fudgy
on the inside the fact that i made this
brownie and i only use the sun
as the energy and it tastes this good
that is that is a win
for me for life so that's very cool it's
getting
a plus plus extra credit okay guys we're
done
we cooked with the sun it was really fun
and quite an adventure
does this work well well it did boil the
water it actually got it to a rolling
boil
which is pretty crazy it took a long
time and didn't boil that much water
it made kind of iffy eggs they were
cooked but they were not cooked
evenly or well but then it made some
really really delicious brownies the
price of this guy is 129
that's pretty expensive i don't think
that this is for a casual
camper i'm gonna give him a middle
thumbs just because it's a very specific
product for a specific type of person
i wouldn't necessarily take it on a
camping trip but it did work and it's a
pretty cool product
all right that's it it was so fun
cooking with the sun with you guys
let us know if there's any other gadgets
you want us to try out and until next
time
bye bye son thank you
for your help oh yes
[Music]
do